- This is cinnamon?
- [Producer] Yeah.
- Why does it smell so not cinnamon?
(laughs)
- Whoa.
(peppy Christmas jingles)
- Hey, what's up everyone?
My name is Tway and welcome
to a special edition of
Making It Big, the show where
my friends challenge me to
make their favorite foods big.
If you notice that my table
here is a little warped
that's because we're
filming everything in VR.
I know.
Really, really cool.
If you wanna watch the full
VR episode, you can watch it
with a Meta Quests two
headset in Mega Tasty.
That's our virtual cooking world
within Horizon Worlds or on Meta Quest tv.
Today I have a special spicy guest.
- Hello
- Hi!
- You guys.
The Flavor Force Queen is in my kitchen.
Thank you so much for blessing
me with your presence.
- Thank you for having me.
- [Tway And Jing] Happy Holidays.
- I have a very special
challenge for you today.
I know you're probably expecting
something really spicy.
- Yeah.
- but I'm gonna lean sweet today.
- Oh?
- I think it's everyone's
favorite dessert for the holidays.
It is a cinnamon roll.
- You want me to make it big?
- I do.
I want you to make the
world's biggest cinnamon roll.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Jing] The icing to dough
ratio needs to be on point.
- [Tway] Okay.
- [Jing] You know, I like my sauce.
Icing is like sweet sauce.
- If I don't succeed, I will
just get you one from the mall.
(Jing and Tway laugh)
- That's a decent constellation
prize, but I believe in you.
- Thank you.
- So, I will see you soon.
- I'll see you later.
- All right. Good luck.
- Wow. Okay.
Let's make a big, giant cinnamon roll.
(holiday music)
- I'm gonna start off by making the dough.
So I have all purpose flour here
and I'm also using whole wheat flour.
This is going to help
with the structure of the cinnamon roll.
I have my sugar here.
Oh, and by the way, this is
only one batch of the dough.
Some salt, ginger, and yeast.
This dry mix.
So this is 16 whole eggs.
There's actually 32 in the recipe.
A lot of butter in this recipe.
And hey, I'm not mad at it.
I love butter.
I just feel like everything
in life that's good,
is bad for you and that's just not fair.
I have my milk over here.
Molasses.
Oh, yeah.
So this is a holiday recipe,
and that's why we're using molasses
to give it that, you know,
extra holiday flavor.
All right, and I think it's
time to add the dry in.
Working with this much
dough kind of scares me,
because I just hope that it rises.
For next season, can production get like
a commercial mixer or what?
Are we just gonna continue
to do this by hand?
Ooh.
Think I'm ready to put
this out onto the counter.
Here we go.
So my dough is getting
there, but in the meantime
Tiny Tway is here to
entertain us with some facts.
So let's hear it.
So it was the Egyptians and the Romans
that had the original sticky bun,
but it was actually the Swedish
and the German immigrants
that brought their version
of the sticky buns to America.
And it wasn't until the
1950s where the cinnamon role
as we know it, the ones
that I'm making now
was created and gained popularity.
I think we are ready to go in the bowls.
(upbeat ticking music)
So while the dough is rising
I'm going to make the filling,
literally the best part
of the cinnamon roll.
So I have the basics here,
the butter and the brown sugar
A lot of butter.
Brown sugar here.
And you can just like stop here.
But like, I want to make this special
for Jing because I love Jing.
So I have all these spices here for her.
- [Voice Affect] Spice it up!
- Molasses, ginger salt, nutmeg,
cinnamon, five spice, cloves.
I love that all these spices
are the spices to make pho,
but we're making cinnamon rolls.
Imagine a pho cinnamon roll.
I don't know if that sounds good,
but like it's a possibility
if it shares the same ingredients. Right?
There you go.
Oh man. What a big boy.
And I think it's time
for another ASMR. Listen.
(rolling pin stick)
Wow.
I have my filling here.
Ooh. Mm
I'm just going to spread
it all over this dough.
Besides eating the
cinnamon roll, this has to
be my favorite part of
making a cinnamon roll.
(happy piano music)
The moment that I've been
not looking forward to
because this can make or
break my cinnamon roll.
(tense string music)
So usually with the regular
cinnamon rolls, at this point
you just cut this, put it
on the tray, let it rise.
But we're not making
regular cinnamon rolls.
We're making a big one.
So I'm gonna continue to keep rolling.
(excited band music)
Oh
What I'm gonna do is cut this
in half and just kind of like patch it.
You know?
(festive orchestration music)
I think it can only fit one more.
I wanna leave a little
room for it to expand.
Let's bake this bad boy.
(happy holiday music)
Again, I have butter.
What's new?
This recipe just has so much butter.
Cream cheese,
and then I have my vanilla extract here
and my salt,
the powdered sugar.
I have some milk over here
that I'm going to just add in slowly.
Got to taste test. Got to.
Oh my gosh, that is so, so delicious.
Let's crush up some cookies.
I'm not angry, I promise.
Oh yeah.
I've just, I've never.
(upbeat music)
- Gorgeous.
This is my big, giant cinnamon roll.
So proud.
- [Tway] This is it.
I'm really hoping to get Jing's approval,
and I think she's here.
Come on in, Jing.
- Hi. Oh my God.
- Okay. Are you ready?
- I think so, yes.
- Okay. Three, two.
(Tway laughing)
- Oh
- This is the giant cinnamon
roll that you asked for.
- Oh my God.
- It looks exactly like the cinnamon roll
I gave you earlier, but giant.
- [Tway] Are you ready?
- [Jing] I am ready.
- My.
- You need some help?
(sad trumpet sound)
(both laughing)
- All right.
- Thank you, Cole.
- Take two.
Yes!
- Oh my God.
- Oh my Lord.
Here we go.
- Wow.
- Here's your slice of cinnamon roll.
- All right.
- [Tway And Jing] Cheers.
- Hmm
- Mm.
What I love is that it's not too dense
and you see how there's
so many flaky layers
and with all the, you know,
the spices layered in between.
That is exactly what I asked for,
and what I was looking for.
So you did great.
- [Tway] Shall we take
this home and finish it?
- Let's do it.
- All right. Let's go.
- Need help carrying?
- Yeah let's do it.
- Wow, wow
- I'll, I'll get the lights later.
- Okay.
(holiday jazz music)